Okay, so it's it's more like recording like this not not like that
Right
Like they're not they're not like talking down like this to the people. It's all just like this. Yeah, so I should bring that up
Or like could this be over there and everything's out to the people and we can shoot it like this
Right
Sure
Sorry guys
It's like the people can see there.
Can we get a round of applause, not only for our team, but for you guys for really coming
coming together and making this event happen.
Well, like I said, hello everyone.
My name is Elaine Pritchett.
I am the Director of Sales and Marketing here.
I have the coolest job.
Take a look around.
It's been a blast.
I bet you're taking over next year, Lloyd.
See, that's why you can't leave.
Anyway, a couple reminders, raffle tickets.
If you guys have any tickets,
I want you to come up here to the front
and put them in the owner's or the employee's bin
because we will be drawing this directly after the product pitch okay one other
thing anybody who's got a product pickup order you got little tags for them today
they are available around the side of the building once you guys are ready to
go you're welcome to go over there and pick up your product there will be a
little bit of a lineup later on so if you do get a chance to go out there
before that that would be excellent okay today we've kind of done something a
little bit different we have something very very special for you we've reached
out to all of you we asked you if you would like to pitch a product at how
many people have been standing in their salon and thought oh my god this would
make an amazing product why does it why isn't this ingredient in this product
we thought about this coconut in it well you guys definitely
Well, you know what, we got a lot of applications, and a lot of them came in from across the
country.
We received some from Newfoundland, from British Columbia, and quite a few from Ontario.
So I want to give everybody a round of applause for A, submitting an application, and a second
round of applause for our five participants.
This is very intimidating for them.
so judges up here as well our judges are going to be rating these products you will see a rating
from 1 to 100 on their whiteboard so at the end of the product pitch they will be rating them we
do have a QR code that you're able to scan as well we want you guys to judge these products
as well. There is a QR code. I'm assuming it's on that TV down there. Okay. Okay, good. So at the
end of the presentation, there will be a QR code. You guys will scan it with your phones and you'll
be able to judge the products as well. Okay. So you're definitely involved. The louder you are,
the more excited you are about products. It resonates, right? So we will definitely have
a winner today we've got three amazing product prices of uh anywhere from two to five hundred
dollars guys so we're paying these people for their hard work as well okay um okay so like i
said we've got five expert judges these judges combined have over a hundred years of experience
period. Actually Nick you won that. Yeah you did. Nick was born into this industry guys.
He definitely won that. Our first judge actually joins us from St. Louis, Missouri. Welcome Gina.
Gina wave. Next we welcome Jess. Jess is right across the border in Michigan. She's our neighbor.
She's our dear friend. They're all our friends, but she's the closest. Welcome. Welcome, Jess.
Our next two guests left the Florida heat, brought it with them, right? We've got Brandon
from Enovay, formerly known as Sunless Inc. And Mikayla from Devoted Creation.
You guys had the, you guys were able to play some games and meet all of our other vendors as well.
So, like I said before, we are very lucky to have them with us and their support means a lot.
Appreciate that.
So, I'm going to pass the mic over to Leanne and she's going to introduce our first product pitch.
I have been literally part of the furniture at ULX for almost 20 years now.
So, I am so, so excited to be up here with Elaine as part of this product pitch presentation.
I know I can see there's quite a few of you that are still back here.
Maybe you want to have a better view.
We can fill in this area a little bit more, and you're more than welcome to fill up the stairs a bit if you want a better view, okay?
I want everybody to have a chance to see what's going on if they can.
For those of you who don't see everything or feel that you don't have the best view, we are recording this presentation.
So this presentation will then be emailed out to those of you in attendance so you can watch it again, okay?
All right.
Alright, so without further ado, I'm going to bring up our first presenter, Ms. Sherry Hawk.
Sherry, you can come on over here. Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Yeah, there's a mic there for you on the table.
Alright, don't cut me yet, Lloyd.
Sherry Hawk is from Sun HQ in Curtis, Ontario.
And Sherry, can you please tell us about your product?
Pretend you're stuck on an elevator with me for two minutes.
And give me your best pitch.
You're on.
Bold, please.
It's called Glovers.
It's not just about color, it's about radiant, healthy skin.
Glovers is a bronzer with a pop of hydration.
Moisture-free, pop, as you immerse your skin with hydration.
An airless pump allows for easy dispensing,
and a peachy silicone-encased bottle makes the product pop on your shelf.
Notes of pineapple and mango refresh the senses
and bring uplifting freshness, ending with a sun-kissed, glowing skin.
Thank you, Sherry.
Now, for those of you concerned that you haven't seen the product,
you will see them at the end when you go in on the screen.
Oh, it is on the screen down there.
Oh, perfect.
All right, you guys are ahead of me.
I thought you were going to have to wait for the QR code,
but you have a visual.
That's excellent.
All right, so I'm going to pass this over to our judges.
Who's got the first question?
Michaela.
So, the beads in there, you said they're moisture beads, right?
Correct.
What do they offer that any other ingredients, like a moisturizing ingredient, what do they offer beyond those?
It gives an added texture to the product.
So, if you think back to, I believe, back in the old days, there was a lotion called Ganja.
And when you pumped it, it would crack kind of coming through.
so it kind of gives that added experience or sensory experience when it's coming through.
Be filled with like hyaluronic acid or vitamin E to just give that pop for the sensory portion of
kind of adding it to your skin. Question about the formula like the feel is it more like a
silicone base is it able to be like one of those hybrid products where you can you know use it in
in the UV bed as well?
Nope, we're gonna stay clear of that.
DHA bronzer in it, and silicone-free.
And then I have one last question,
and that's about the airless pump.
Yes.
I know a lot of people get confused about airless pumps,
just because sometimes anger can kind of get stuck in there,
and then you don't take a second to pump it out,
and then it's like, kind of over-enacted or anything.
Crazy thing.
Is there any other tube or component you guys
that ever considered beyond the airless pump? No, we really like the airless pump because then you
know you're getting 100% of your product out. Ambrosia was a huge product with an airless pump,
went through different versions of it including the cooling one and it was just nice to kind of
see your product as it was emptying, you knew how close you were to the end, so we really like that.
Okay, I'm gonna have one last one, sorry. You said DHA, about how much DHA would you say,
somewhere lower the middle range middle range uh thank you this is a great pitch i i just have to
say i love those the tie-in between the name first the the description of like reads that pop as well
as the the crushable scent i think you just did a really cool job and kind of tying that whole theme
kind of throughout the whole product thank you
to be fair one of our girls it started from fruity pebbles really yeah that's one of the
girls said we want something in it that looks like that you can see the texture something like
fruity pebbles that's the reason for the cutout in the bottle where you see those texture beads
oh very cool yeah love that idea you might not be able to see it on there but if you yeah there
you go yeah what do you feel is your price point 18 to 35 um we're looking for people
um young style conscious experienced tanner um trend aware active on social media
sephora shoppers tick tockers yeah i can see i can see the product especially among some of
the influencer or just a mullet.
Right.
The pop and the bird's eye shows.
Exactly.
We won't go there.